all right congresswoman Alexandra Acacio
Cortez says her green new deal will save
the planet in exchange we just give up
cars and airplanes and rebuild every
structure in the United States well also
by the way need to invent brand-new
forms of energy that science hasn't
conceived of yet how much will this cost
that's unclear how will we pay for it
unknown who will make this happen will
workers obviously though anyone who is
quote unwilling to work will still get
paid by the government in other words
not all of the details have been ironed
out as of tonight that's why we're
grateful the Robert Hawkins is here he's
a law professor at Cornell he's advising
Alexandria cosmic Cortes on the green
new deal and he joins us professor
thanks very much for coming on so cuz
that's the obvious question why would we
ever pay people who are quote unwilling
to work I we never would write an AOC
has never said anything like that right
I think you're referring to some sort of
a document that some I think some
doctors document that somebody other
than us has been circulating oh I
thought that came right from her that
was in the background or from her office
as my understand no no she's actually
tweeted it out to laugh at it if you
look at her latest tweets it seems that
apparently some Republicans have put it
out there I don't know well then thank
you for correcting me I mean because
ditka almost as ridiculous as the idea
that we're going to build enough light
rail to make airplanes unnecessary which
I think actually is from I don't know
where you got that you either Tucker I
actually believe that you're actually on
our side about this if you actually read
the actual plan right there's nothing
about getting read anything it's about
expanding many options right I mean
there are many many things we want to be
able to do now in addition to what we
already do so was where's the airplane
disappearance coming from I'm not really
clear on where well I could actually get
it for you this is that would be grave
your questions released by her office
and I'm quoting from it yeah maybe this
maybe this is fraudulent in which case I
hope you'll correct me but it says that
the green new deal would and I'm quoting
totally overhaul transportation and that
would mean quote building out high-speed
rail at a scale where air travel would
stop becoming necessary
okay Senator Hawaii said an easy Hirono
respond to that by saying that would be
hard for Hawaii's so I don't think
that's made up
but I mean it apparently is being
misunderstood right we're really talking
about expanding optionality here we're
not talking about getting rid of
anything right we're talking about
basically making a cost effective to
move into more modern forms of
Technology more modern forms of
production which would then enable
people actually cost-effectively to
transition to that stuff we're not we're
talking about requiring anything or
prohibiting anything that's sort of a DS
style environment okay but I don't wait
hold on I don't I don't want you to back
away from what she herself has said and
all of this with the caveat that you
know a lot of this one happened maybe
none of it but these are the ideas that
she's articulating she did so on NBC
will miss you Tucker I won't back away
from anything she said well yeah we're
going to supplant all fossil fuels in 12
years yes yes so yes okay so that
doesn't mean that doesn't mean stop
that's would be prohibiting them it
means rendering them obsolete by doing
something better and we can and it's
nice to have a smart person on the show
to explain this what about air travel
which is critical to our economy this is
a continental country it stays the same
okay but no because that requires fossil
fuel that might we're not talking about
we're talking about carbon neutrality
remember we're talking about net zero
emissions that doesn't mean that there's
never any burning of anything right I
mean until we come up with solar panel
flying airplanes of course we're not I'm
sorry I'm starting erupted you I just
want to correct you I just had because
this seemed like we were making news on
the show the unwilling to work thing was
in her background er that has been
absolute confess
definitely not definitely not okay so
NBC that's weather news outlets are
saying that that was in the background
and yes that's fraudulent at's erroneous
right now there might be new details now
that you know about that I don't because
I've been doing media all day but the
story old yeah I think that was actually
in the document I mean as a kid man well
you said wrong it's the wrong document
Tucker we're not getting rid of fossil
fuels actually even though you just said
yes no no we're rendering them obsolete
for most purposes that use for now right
but arable is a huge source food source
hence the word most before right we
eliminate them for most purposes we got
two gasoline-powered cars but imagine
how much better it's going to be when
it's cost-effective to drive electric
cars but that can't be done simply by
individuals right you have to coordinate
you have to have charging stations
everywhere and of course individuals can
do that right so in that sense the
government is acting like a kind of
orchestra conductor here we're trying to
coordinate right some of that stuff that
could only be central coordinate you can
enable everybody to act individually
without within that framework right yeah
that doesn't I don't fully understand
what you're saying but let me just I
mean on the low end this would be the
most expensive thing that the United
States has ever undertaken
it wouldn't be looting rural
electrification the second world war and
I'm just kind of wondering in a country
that's got more debt than it has GDP how
would we pay for that well here's the
key right remember that we racked up
enormous debt to finance the second
world war effort and the meteo and of
course the interstate highway system in
the 50s but here's the key point here's
a takeaway I want you to remember this I
hope everybody will remember this
remember that inflation is a relation
right it's the relation between the
quantity of money and the quantity of
goods
now if the money that you're spending is
resulting in the production of a great
many more Goods you have no inflation
problem more production absorbs more
expenditure the problem with the seven
trillion dollars that was spent during
the Bush years and a person's last tax
cut was that it wasn't actually
productive but note that even that
didn't bring about inflation okay by the
way I'm just getting all this in my ear
and we're actually gonna follow up with
this next week
okay then I'm willing to work line which
are obviously embarrassed about and you
should be embarrassing no Tucker we're
not embarrassed by what's not ours okay
and I hope you will come back I will
thank you thanks I'm glad I'm always
grateful people in their side come on
including you thank you